quelles sont les femmes et les hommes
les plus élégants du monde
la question préoccupe ce genre jacques
dufour qui depuis hier soit avec l'aide
de jean claude brialy à la réponse non
charlotte de courgettes ne figurait pas
au palmarès mais au menu du dîner
précédant la remise des prix destinés à
récompenser l'élégance d'une vingtaine
de personnalités parmi les lauréats
marina vlady qui nous résume l'esprit de
la soirée
c'est l'élégance et
peut-être ainsi dans une ambiance très
jet set les uns et les autres sur leurs
récompenses certains comme lelouch avec
un peu d'étonnement
je fais toujours des blousons je
m'habille jamais je prends jamais
vraiment c'est pas mon problème dont je
pense que ce soir je suis récompensé
pour
pour mes films
et plus concours sachez que britney de
scène comédienne aux appâts à guichen
est aussi best 88 tout comme louis
féraud qui a une définition très
personnelle de l'élégance élégance et
anor chez un homme c'est toujours dehors
des jambes kilti veut plus longue si
madame butô et monsieur gandhi ne purent
venir recevoir leur prix robert wagner
en revanche n'hésita pas à franchir
l'atlantique pour cette consécration
quant à gina lollobrigida radieuse et
bien elle nous a avoué que sa vie
devenait un enfer puisqu'elle devait
sauter d'avion en avion pour recevoir
les diverses récompenses qui s'abattent
sur elle en amérique la fin de l'année
etc
la femme élégante demain encore un autre
prix en italie
je dois prendre l'avion pour recevoir à
l'homme le prix une vie pour le cinéma
c'était en quelque sorte une soirée dans
la vie des best
quelle vie